we are swish on oolitic swish is a
machine learning platform for sports
data specifically focused on predictive
insights for the sports betting and
fantasy worlds as well as real-time
predictions we are collecting thousands
of data points before the game and
obviously during the game and we are
producing a number of different
predictions so if our models feel that
the next play will be a pass that is
obviously going to affect the potential
output for a receiver on the team versus
a run where it would be a have a bigger
impact on the running back we're taking
a lot of data and trying to simplify it
and then try to package that into three
simple picks for our users to then place
at their bookies their online betting
site or with their friends definitely
daily fantasy is where you see the best
application of this kind of predictive
analytics we are helping the common fan
leverage this powerful technology
leverage this you know amazing data in
really simple and easy-to-use tools
we're allowing you to plug into our
platform not have any prior knowledge
and come out with a winning lineup that
will continue to evolve as the fantasy
games become more complex and decisions
become more real-time focus variety and
overall velocity and an increased amount
of these games is probably where you're
going to see the biggest growth for fans
from a viewing standpoint you'll see
much more granular predictions much more
granular gamification around sports so
now people are making bets in real time
during a game or playing fantasy that
will grow to seriously seriously detail
levels where you could be making live
in-game wagers on every different
scenario that can happen throughout a
game so it'll increase the gamification
and kind of the excitement around the
sport probably exponentially over the
next 10 to 20 years
you will see a lot of people realize
especially as sports betting opens up in
the u.s. that there is an opportunity to
make money but the only way to do so is
to treat it like an investment strategy
so it's not hey you're going to win
tonight one bet it's over the course of
a season you will be profitable and beat
out the returns of some of the best
hedge funds or mutual funds or financial
instruments you can find it's possible
that in the future supercomputers will
not just affect gameplay and fantasy but
may open the door to effect in a whole
new strategy your retirement